and uh
we
um i guess i better start this morning
by recapitulating a little bit where we
are but the main theme for today in the
four lectures will be uh the
uh the the guts of tech the inner parts
that really uh uh
do most of the processing inside
and tomorrow's theme is going to be the
things that uh are going to be a primary
concern to people in this audience uh
how they
what
they really want to know about the uh
the the things that are going to be
slightly different from one place to
another
so to uh
remind you of this
of the structure of tech itself somebody
asked yesterday could they have a copy
of this diagram and so i made up xerox
copies we'll pass these out now
and start start them going in two
directions
um
so you can get a feeling for
where we are now this is remember that i
said this part was the code
and each box represents about 10 modules
in your listing
so when we were talking yesterday
about the dynamic memory in the last
hour this represents the amount of code
there was for the dynamic memory but the
dynamic memory itself was taking a lot
more space that we that
might
might overlap this whole diagram by
at least half of it but maybe maybe all
of it for the dynamic memory itself then
the the eqtb the equivalence table
was um
uh
is what i call locals here this is the
part of the uh this is the part of the
program that that refers to saving and
restoring the equivalence and defining
all the macros that we had for
equivalent
on in
the first lecture that we're having this
morning i want to study this part
syntax
which is uh the part that of tech that
reads the input and figures out what to
do next
then next hour we'll be talking about
semantics which is doing it
okay any questions on what we're about
to do
so then we'll go back in
and
take a look at that listing
so certainly i can't cover all of the
all of the ideas of syntax in one hour
but what i want to do is give you the
feeling for for how it's organized so
that if you have any particular
uh
question on it you know exactly
where to look and uh
the
sections on syntax
start out with part 21 module 277
introduction to the syntactic routines
and then um that carries on through
a sec part 27 building token lists that
the basic scanning subroutines part 26
system is the bulk of the thing it's a
that's about 55 modules worth in that
uh in that section and i'll probably
talk a lot about basic scanning
since i can't cover everything the
approach i usually take is is uh
trying to to do a sample
a random sample study
study the whole thing lightly and one
thing in depth and and thereby get some
some idea
i'm not sure which one to study in depth
and maybe i can take some suggestions
from the audience as we get into it but
first i should we should start out just
with the basic idea of syntax
what we have to do
the goal of syntax is to
deliver
uh
is is to scan the input and and deliver
the the necessary information to the uh
semantic routines and
at the uh
at the level the semantic routine wants
it it usually wants to get a command
and a modifier to the command which is
which is called chur
uh a larger sometimes is a pointer not
really a character
uh so we have a command code and a
character
part and then there's also um
cs pointer goes with it in case the
thing that you fetched from the input
was a control sequence then the command
will
will maybe be um
i'm sorry the cs pointer will point to
whatever
control sequence actually gave this had
this command ensure
um so that in k in an error message for
example um
uh
you you
uh you'd like to use the
the control sequence that actually
caused this thing somebody in in tech
can say let
um
backslash a equals uh
uh def or something like this well now
if i have a or whatever if you've
decided to redefine text primitive
called def
and the user is using some other name
for it then you have an error message uh
um
you would like to use the the new name
in the error message rather than the the
old one so cs pointer is another thing
you get from the input routine
so that the thing that delivers the next
token
is called get next
subroutine get next
and its job is to get the next token of
input
now um might sound like an easy job
uh after all you just advance your
pointer one in the buffer and there it
is right
however get next
uh turns out to
have a lot of different things that it
might be having to get for example it
had it might have to
um
expand a macro it might have to uh be
reading an argument on macro it might
have to recognize the control sequence
whether it's defined or not and look it
up in the hash table
it might have it might find that in
order to get the next thing
actually we have to prompt for it
because there because it hasn't been
given to us yet
might run to the end of a file
and and uh
or uh
you know so if we get to the end of the
file that means that we have to close
out that file do some processing
all kinds of
things can actually happen when you say
get next
historically in fact the get next was
the routine that started this whole web
project going we took the uh
we took the
get next procedure out of tech 78
and we
we said well how would how would we
really want to present this this code
and we and we played around with luis
and i uh tried several drafts until we
until we had played around with uh with
two so we got to what we thought would
be a good way to present
the get next routine and uh
uh and that led that to the doc system
of two years ago and eventually to to
web so it was uh it was um had enough uh
structure and some parts to it that it
that that it was really our first test
case for the whole idea of this style of
documentation
the get next routine
is is
it begins in module 317
and
the whole the structure of it is is
given there so the ket next it by itself
looks looks very simple let's see if we
can
if we can get if we can focus on this uh
can you can you read that with your tv
cam
with your camera
let's try to get
see if we can set up the way we had
yesterday yet uh
uh
uh okay you need enough light not on on
my podium in order to read the uh
in order to see where my finger is but
then people on the screen could might
could see where i'm pointing if they if
they project onto the screen
what's going on the monitor
it worked yesterday but it might take a
little bit of a figuring to to
to to do it here now i've got something
on the screen here and i'm pointing to
get next
uh can oh you can see a finger yeah well
is that about all okay somebody said
that they could shut the door back there
and that would make the light that would
make it easier to to read the screen
you know
yeah okay so um the whole idea of get
next is
uh is is rather simple then we have a
couple of labels in here restart uh if
we have if for some reason what we tried
to get uh resulted in nothing so we have
to have to start again uh then there's
some other some other switches that we
go to but the code is forget next is
very short except that we that involves
a couple of sub modules so
um
we set cs pointer to zero cs pointer is
going to be zero unless there was a
control sequence gotten
that's why uh the eqtb starts at
location one instead of zero because the
first control sequence actually is is uh
is one
uh now um
then state is one of the variables that
we
have set up for us all the time at our
fingertips
to tell us what kind of uh what kind of
input we're doing if the state is token
list that means that we're getting we're
getting something not from the user
source file but from um
from inside of tech from some token list
that that
we have to read through and and get the
next symbol off that token list the
token list can be about about 10
different kinds uh
the
for example
it could be an output routine it could
be a macro it could be
every par this feature that comes up at
the beginning of a paragraph it could be
the parameter to a macro uh could be
something that we inserted just to back
up we read we read some token we decided
we weren't ready for it now so we put it
back and we've been into a small token
list and so we can read it again it
might be something like we converted a
number to roman numerals
and we want to read that so anyway token
so tokenlist is one way we can get input
but if it's not tokenlist if the state
is not tokenlist then we get input from
an external file and we would go to
restart if there wasn't anything found
otherwise
we of course want an input from a token
list
and we have other cases where we might
have to go to restart because there was
nothing there yet
so
two main branches of get next for those
two cases then if we've got to the end
of an alignment entry then we have to do
something special for alignment here's
one one of the places where this post
hypnotic suggestion comes in with
alignment saying that
for example if you if you just now got
to a
tab mark in alignment this is the time
to
emit uh the uh
the thing that's supposed to finish off
that column
and so you do a little bit of special
calculation for alignment if you just
happen to notice that this if it gets
triggered right here in the middle of
get next now that
get next is part of the inner loop of
the code
certainly uh when we the first part of
it here this restart cs pointer to zero
and so on and i talked a little bit
about inner loop yesterday now if you
want to find out exactly where i think
most of the time is spent in tech you
look in the index and under inner loop
and it refers you to about 20 modules
which i believe are the ones that that
account for almost all of the all the
processing time
in the sense that the other ones are
probably executed in order magnitude
less
and
not all of these modules are
are executed very often but uh
so we we try to write the program so
that the frequent parts
are done rather fast and and i think my
estimate is something like 100 machine
instructions
uh per per character
of text is uh is approximately right i
have to double check it again now that
i've got the whole tech put together but
that was if you consider uh
what would happen if you took a text
file added one more character to one of
the paragraphs
um how many more machine
instructions would the cpu have to do
and it was on the order of 100 i believe
and that and we tried to keep that uh
going fast
so
we want uh
we want get next in particular to to be
reasonably reasonably fast and uh if
we're inputting from an external file
we go to module 319.
module 319
is a switch
that
we're reading from an external file now
so our state actually the state consists
of of a number of different things five
or six different quantities actually
correspond to the to the current input
state
and one of them is called uh
which we looked at to see if it was
tokenless or not another one is called
loc
which is the location where we are in
the buffer
and another one is called limit which is
the end of that line in the buffer now
in the buffer we might have
lots of different lines we might have
part of a line from a terminal we have
we then then we we were reading some
file and in the middle of that line it
said input from another file
and uh so so we might have
several different things in the buffer
but the in limit tells where that where
the current line ends
and if it's a local less than or equal
limit and current line is not yet
finished and so we have to do the thing
that we're almost always doing now when
the lock is greater than limit though
then we have an unusual case not in the
inner loop
and that is moved to the next line of
file or go to restart if there is no
next line in the file
and uh so we do that and that's a time
when we can also check and interrupt
um
there's a
a provision if you can do it in your
system for interrupts uh uh
for interrupting tech and at safe times
to make an interrupt i'll say check
interrupt there aren't many places where
i do it
but this is this is a fairly good place
at the end of a line of in in the buffer
so any uh if you um
at the end of a token list is another is
another place and uh this happens fast
enough that
if somebody's sitting there and wants to
stop the tech run or do something
special you can probably catch it
in in one of those places
now
and
the the main case though the one that
that's that we want to be at high speed
is this first line here
uh where loca is less than or equal
limit because that's the the case when
that we're most interested in getting to
go fast okay so then we set current char
per char to
buffer position buffer lock so buffer
is a is an array of ascii code
characters this is text internal code
and uh
all the external file has been converted
to that and sits in the buffering x in
in internal code form
increased location and then we go to uh
set up the current command which is the
chicode of the kerchar
now to code of kerchar is
really this is a macro that's an
abbreviation for get out of the eqtb
the current value of the uh
of the of the code for that character
we have um made sure elsewhere that this
that this is going to be in range
nobody's allowed to store into that part
of eqtb a number that's uh uh that's uh
uh that couldn't possibly be a chikota
of a character i think the only the
legal ones are zero to 15. so this uh
this is known to be current command is
now known to be a number between zero
and 15.
and then we have the big uh thing that
that changes state and go to switch if
the current character should be ignored
so now in the tech manual i have a
chapter that sort that sort of says what
this states are and how we're how we're
actually reading so we have a state that
says
we're skipping blanks if we're in
skipping blank state then
if a blank comes next we skip it and so
on there's there's three states actually
mid line new line and skipping blanks
and we want this to be fast so that's
module 320 let's take a look at what
that is so module 320
is a big case
statement and and it's done by case of
state plus ker command
so the state is now
encoded as a number that is uh
1 17 or 33 i believe it is so that the
current command
being between 0 and 15 added to the
state will take us to a unique location
no sense multiplying here we're in the
inner loop we might as well define the
state code so that it already includes
the multiplication by 16.
um and and uh so then we can have a
state
of
various states like well here's an
example
midline plus spacer midline plus
carriage return
skip blanks plus carriage return
any state plus end line
any state plus is a
is a macro that's defined to to
it's defined over here
where was it here any state plus
can anybody
yeah any state plus uh midline so that
that adds midline plus the thing skip
length plus the thing new line plus
thing so anyway this is the way we
recognize uh it's a it's a uh
16 it's a 48 way switch
that will at high speed decide what to
do next
um
okay uh if for example we get any state
plus escape we have to scan a control
sequence
and then um set state to skip blanks
because we're going to skip a blank
after control sequence that's the way
this this part of the code looks and uh
the
the number of machine instructions
actually needed for this is supposed to
be rather small if you and
if your compiler really does terrible
things with case statements
then you might want to take take the the
the few places in the inner loop where
there's a case statement and uh and and
do something special to the uh
to that part of the program
uh that as a refinement but it will make
tech run faster if you can make this
part run
um
five percent faster your attack will
probably run four percent faster
so uh
something like that
i think is uh
is worth pointing out now the on if you
have a token list um that starts at
module 333
and uh so the token list
again we have state state information
besides the the state the the uh the
thing variable called state itself
will equal token list but then loc in
this case will be a pointer to
what token is next in the uh in the mem
in the memory array
and if that's null then we might uh you
know we're at the end of the token list
but if it's not null then we we fetch
out of the token uh the command and char
and cs pliner
just as if we had scanned it out of the
input
and uh otherwise if it's null then again
we have one of these things where we
where we can end a token list
i
thought
that i
i guess end token list itself is where
the is where it would check for an in or
out
okay and i am surprised i don't see a
pause for interrupt in there but i i
suppose it's in end token list itself i
i don't want to take time to look it up
now um one thing i wanted to mention
about this is that you'll notice then
the control sequence never doesn't live
in
mem
by its alphabetic name
the only control sequence is certain is
represented
as
as the as an address in eqtb
in that token and so uh the only time
you're ever
you're ever s uh looking at it at a
control sequence to figure out what its
hash address is is when that is when
that appeared in a file
only when the the only time you are
scanning
you
have to
compute a hash code to figure out where
the eqtp address is is in the first case
of get next where you saw an escape
delimiter in the file so
if you have a long or short macro name
it doesn't make any difference when
you're actually using the macro how long
that name was it only took a little
longer for a long name at the first when
you input the thing into uh into a token
list in the first place but once
once you've got a
control sequence into a token list it's
just like any other control sequence no
matter how long it's it's actual
external name was
okay
so
um
all of these modules handle then the
there's weird cases of of get next where
we have to do things like a person has
said pause set to non-zero value and uh
in in that case uh that means that after
you've read a new line out of your file
you're supposed to display it on the
terminal give the user a chance to see
what's going on and maybe make a change
to it before tech actually gets it
you have to and
in my change file the only thing i had
to change and get next was
to make it more friendly on our
particular editor at sale which is page
oriented editor so we have not only page
numbers line numbers but we also have
page numbers so like so um
i had to
make sure that
that the page number would get adjusted
when i passed a page mark in the file
um also i spent uh but most of an
afternoon trying to get it to work with
our our line editor which is a special
feature on a system that
allows a user to change the line as as
it comes in
um and edit it with them with some
rather powerful editing commands us that
would search for characters and insert
characters in the line and so on um
uh and i and i
made made the uh
this part of the pro of the get next
routine uh talk to that system routine
so it's certainly not standard in pascal
so i had to do those two things in the
change file for forget next
now that now um
almost all uses of get next are covered
in the next part of the program they're
starting at 3 38
and
the most common way to call get next
is
is get
nc token
if you look at the rest of tech you'll
find and you find out where is get next
actually use you think well this would
be one of the most common subroutines to
call
uh because you need to get the next
token a lot in a lot of different places
and continue on advancing to do
something but if you look in the index
under get next uh for the uses of it you
find that it's only only used in about
four places um but those but uh it's
used in get nc token
and and most of the other times in tech
when we when we want the next thing we
actually get
we actually call this subroutine instead
of the other one the only exception to
that
is
well i'm sorry the only place where
where the main body of tech itself calls
get next is in the inner loop where we
want to avoid an extra level of
procedure overhead of get nc token
and so in the in the very inner loop
where you're scanning a word out of a
paragraph and looking for ligatures and
things like this where you expect that
the next letter is the next thing is
just going to be a letter then you call
get next in order to avoid getting nc
token and then if you look at it and it
looks like it's something that's more
complicated then uh we'll call a
subroutine and leave the inner loop
so uh this inner loop has uh has a
the idea of making it efficient has has
uh
affected the uh according to a small to
a certain extent uh makes it a little
harder to read but only i think only one
only one percent harder so it was okay
now get nc token
is like get next but it does it does
more it
nc stands for non-call and call is a is
a macro that's that uh or you know that
has to be expanded so get nc token
means that if if it's get next but if it
turned out the next thing was a macro uh
expand it and and and get me the next
thing that isn't a macro
so this is the so when i call get nc
token this says let me see whatever is
next but be sure that it doesn't include
any control it's not something that's
been depth
furthermore um
get nc token
sets besides
command and char in fact it's called ker
command and kerchar
are other variables that get next then
it says ker talk
which is the which is a token a half
word representation of the command in
char and cs pointer
so that you can
you can have one variable that that uh
stands for all of the others pat in a
packed form uh this is this is
convenient if you want to store it away
in another token list or something like
that
you can use it or if you have to back up
it's all ready to be backed up
so so get nc token
gives you the values of kirk command
kerchar cs pointer and kurtok which and
this is enough by itself to deduce the
other three
um
get nc token is uh
is the
will also expand not only macros but it
will it will um
expand um
marks like top mark or something like
that if you if you want to it's which
because they're somewhat analogous to
macros
um if you if the next token is an
undefined control sequence
get nc token issues you the error
message saying undefined control
sequence because this is where it would
it it would not
let let it get through when you call get
nc token you don't have to check
afterwards that the thing was an
undefined control sequence
get nc token will will already uh remove
all unconfined control sequences from
you and get the next thing that's really
legitimate
um
there's another routine called nc token
i might just mention because it's um
it's used only in the one place in the
inner loop where in the inner loop we
had a place where we expected that
that it was unlikely we'd have a macro
coming next and so we called get next
it was going to save us
the level of procedure call it would
have said call this first and then that
would call get next just be a little
faster
uh but if we found out that that uh our
assumption was wrong that really get
that really there was a macro there then
we call nc token which is exactly the
same as get nc token except that it
accept uh somehow get nc token is
equivalent to get next
followed by nc token
the other main way to call get next
is called get token
and
this one
does not expand macros
it just gives it to you with uh so the
token that you get you get you get your
cur command you get your kerchar
and your cs pointer
uh and you get kurt token also
but if but it it's possible that kirk
command would be um
a call or long call for calling a long
macro or you know or uh or something
like a marked top mark or an undefined
control sequence it's certainly possible
that get token will return you the name
of a of an undefined control sequence
and this is the thing that you use at
times when you're building a definition
for example after the word def
and then if you say def whatever follows
it you'd say get token you certainly
wouldn't want to say get nc token that
would replace the thing by its previous
definition or give you an error if it
wasn't already defined it would be a big
big tragic mistake
so there are places where we don't where
we definitely want to suppress
macro expansion and that's what get
tolkien does
okay
so the uh
the those routines get token get nc
token are there just uh there were
rather simple routines uh
of module 339 is uh
get token um just to reinforce it let's
let let's uh show you what get token is
this module 339
and it says sets ker command kircher and
kerr talk i
goofed i said kurt token on the board
here i meant kurt tov
and uh okay there's a uh
no new control sequence is set to false
then get next and set no new control
sequence true
the um uh in the middle to get next
routine the there's a part of it that
would have to look that might have to go
and look at the hash table
and
and uh
this and and add a new undefined control
sequence to the hash table now we don't
want to put uh misspelled things in the
hash table if they're going to turn out
to be an error so so uh
generally we have a variable no new
control sequence that says
new control sequences aren't allowed
this is the only place where we said it
false and we set it through afterwards
now this is uh this violates uh
prevailing wisdom about programming
which says that you shouldn't that
global variables are considered harmful
and that you should pass such things as
parameters
but my comments about the inner loop
should indicate why i thought why i feel
that this is actually as long as we're
using it in disciplined way uh we know
what we're doing this is a valid way to
save a lot of time by not saying get
next of
some parameter that says whether or not
a new control sequence is allowed or not
and get next would have to propagate
that down to the hash
routine and a bunch of other things
setting up the
setting up a parameter every time we
call that subroutine
would make tech run a lot slower
all right
so get next this will then allow a new
control sequence to appear
um i guess i made a little lie when i
said that's the only place this is set
fast there's one other place and that's
in any tech when you're first loading
the uh
when you're first loading the hash table
okay then if cs pointer is zero this
means there was no it was not a control
sequence found uh then we do this part
otherwise we set current token equal to
the cs token flag plus cs pointer so
kurt talk is is properly set up and
that's all is to it if we did but it was
zero
then uh there's uh um a fatal error in
here if the current command is nv nv
occurs in alignment and this would
actually uh or be something i'm not even
sure it can ever happen uh but probably
it will it will there but i but if it
would happen i wouldn't have any idea
how to recover from it
and this would mean that somebody is is
uh calling macro without expansion at a
time when it's also possible to uh
to be finishing a column in an alignment
and uh well if you think about it a
while like uh it took i think there's
nothing else to do except give a fatal
error and we'll see what happens if
there's ever if maybe if that turns out
there's a way to recover in a in
a reasonably common case and of course
we would change this part of the code
so i'm going to make the check here
because if i didn't and i allowed it i i
allowed that nv to get through then all
kinds of things could could get screw up
in the rest of tech
so i wanted to trap it here
um
even though this might be the inner loop
and kurtok then is said in this case to
to a packed version of the command and
character
as we mentioned yesterday that's the way
we represent a token
all right those are the basic things
that are that all the rest of tech uh
relies on get token get nc token in
order to look at at its input
any questions on that
okay
now the uh
um
the interesting part of syntax is the
is the
there's a section called basic scanning
subroutines and these are the things
that do higher level
uh parsing
of text source
and uh
well basic scanning
routines start out with some that are
actually pretty pretty dumb
uh there's one called scan left brace
every once in a while tech gets to a
point where it's got to see a left brace
or not or else uh it or else it's stuck
and so it calls scan left brace and and
uh this uh subroutine i think it's
probably used about
15 20 times this is module 363.
um
and uh so it just uh
you know this is this well this is the
typical way that we that we uh recall
something and it says get the next
non-blank non-call token
if the next thing is really a space then
then then uh we won't give an error
message saying missing left brace
because we will keep on going until we
get something besides a space
but then
so so this is a little a little thing
that that gets used very often notice
module 364. this quote is used in
sections 363
rather often we'll say get nc token
until ker command is unequal spacer okay
and then if current command is not a
left brace
then uh then we got this long um
message and here it gives us a chance to
show how those health messages and
errors are a typical error is is is done
um
fatal errors are very unusual but but uh
this kind of error where that where we
give a health message is typical so take
a look at it if we start out with with
print something on a new line in our
error message our official error message
here has uh it starts with the
exclamation point
uh missing left brace inserted now
the help message is uh is then is given
next before i called the error
subroutine
and um and the number of lines of help
is is uh is used here so uh so that i
could stick to simple web macros and uh
so i have a help four for a four line
help message and a help three for three
line help message and so on
uh the help message comes in a left
brace was mandatory here so i put one in
you might want to delete or insert some
corrections so i'll find a matching
right very soon if you're confused by
all this try typing eye
right brace now that's that's the best
way to probably recover if they didn't
yeah but if they had a missing left
brace and i'm going to put one in it it
can also be a problem if there isn't a
right brace somewhere else
then i call back error back error is a
is something that takes current token
and puts it back so that it'll be read
again
and so the next thing get token or get
next we'll see
is uh is uh the the one that it just
already saw
and it backs up and also uh
does those the right things for backing
up and then the current token is set to
a left brace token and
and we pretend that we've read it that's
in agreement with what we said here that
a missing one was inserted
um somebody asked me the other day why
the style of these health messages using
i and you in this mess and then and uh i
believe uh uh there's several reasons
why uh
it's uh it turns out to be a win to have
the computer talking to you as if it as
if it understands i mean or it'll make a
statement like saying uh um i i i don't
understand this or i do understand
something when we all know that computer
doesn't really think well
um
because the the main reason is that that
you can communicate a lot more in a
small space when you when you use the
the english language the way it was
designed to be used and english language
has developed over thousands of years
and and um the thing it's most powerful
at is discourses between
between people and so when we when if we
if we um if we restrict ourselves to
using third person all the time uh then
we then we're
losing a great deal of power of it so so
this so uh in fact
um i i sketched out all kinds of ways to
write health messages and finally this
one turned out to be by far the the one
that gave the most uh uh had the most uh
uh effective i i'm quite convinced of
this
now the help messages have to be at most
60 characters long uh per line
uh and like and i also like to make
those lines uh
break in a somehow reason you know
fairly for a nice way so it was a little
bit of a challenge sometime to take a 61
character work one and figure out what
was the right word uh to substitute but
when when when writing these help
messages i also tried to use words that
were different from the ones in the
official error message that was given
earlier so that person has the error
described in two different ways has a
chance of understanding one of those two
um
so so uh you know
if people here from foreign countries uh
implementing tech
there would like uh to to make uh tech
more friendly there you might
probably
be better to have the help messages
translated into your own native language
or people from the east coast might want
to translate it into east coast english
and so on
uh
so i mean mit is another special case
right
i mean anyone who's reading the help
messages in emacs knows that they have a
language of their own right
so um
now the uh anyway uh we we try to make
the help message uh uh in an iu uh uh
uh
situation and when when you see the new
tech manual with the illustrations uh
you'll also get an idea that we can sort
of personify tech because there's a
character that appears in these
illustrations
who is going to be on all our t-shirts
next year
now the the
uh so this is um
a simple simple use of the or the
scanning and
there's a
slightly more interesting one on the
next page uh case you're getting bored
this one is used to scan a keyword when
we're looking for something like plus or
minus or or for after various words
that that
might be present in any uh
in the text and this one will will look
ahead to see if you've got uh if if you
if you match a keyword
either with upper case or in possibly an
uppercase version of the keyword it's
all done here whenever you're looking
for such a keyword this this function
scan keyword
returns uh yes or no whether it found
the keyword or not if it found it then
we pass it in the input and we we're
ready to read on if it didn't find it we
back up over the partial fines that we
might have made and uh our position back
at where we were before
uh
before we started
okay um
now um
uh the most now but after that we get
into the interesting things uh the
really the really uh uh
important basic scanning routines are
the ones that that recognize high level
constructs in the in the input
for example uh
if if it time comes time for tech to
look for an an integer number then it
can say scan int and it will look for an
integer number
in as the next thing in the input
an integer number
can be uh
an integer number like 12
one followed by two but it could be an
octal so it would be starts if the next
thing we see is a apostrophe then we
start to say well we'll scan and rate in
output notation and one two will mean
ten
um
it might start with a backwards
apostrophe which means we're looking for
a character constant
but integer number might start with a
minus sign of course
then we then we have to have to have all
these options uh again after we've
decided to negate it in fact it well it
can start with a plus sign which is sort
of a no-op uh and we go past the plus
sign and we can have uh a bunch of minus
signs in fact a bunch of minus signs and
plus signs there uh
certain you you it's important when you
have a language that uses macros
to allow minus minus to appear because
uh
otherwise the macros i would have to be
very worried about about not allowing
that to come through so minus minus it
should should be should be legal uh but
besides all of these things and other um
integers can also be stored in text
registers so it might say backslash
count
uh something or other and we're supposed
to recognize that uh and fetch the
current value of the counter um the most
complicated one is when when you say the
in tech 82 this is something that is in
the present text but if you if you want
to give an integer you could you can
start out with the word the
and then the will fetch
many things inside of text
uh internal tables so that will be able
to fetch out for example
any one of the parameters the
hyphenation penalty or something like
that
the
can be used to find out parameters that
have been stored with a particular font
and many other things now
scan intent scan scans integer there's
also scan demand which scans the
dimension
and will return the value
of the dimension right now where they
wrote this it turned out to be better
not to return the value
as the value of a function but to to put
it in a in a global variable
curveval
and again here was a case that it took
that my
my original design was not to use this
global variable but i found out later
that i was getting much better uh re uh
program uh
by by using a global variable for this
purpose so that so curve val is if you
call scan int the answer occurs in
appears in curve l
um now so scan demand is for getting a
dimension a scan skip or scan glue gosh
i forgot what i called it
scan demand starts at 400 and scan glue
yeah scan glue at 4 13. um
so these are three three high level
things the scan blue routine is going to
look for something that is a dimension
and then possibly saying plus some other
amount of stretch ability and then or
minus something or other
um
well
now all of these things three things can
say the for example when you when tech
comes to the point where it wants to
scan
glue
the glue might start with the word the
it might be the baseline skip for
example so if you want to if you want to
do a v skip by the baseline skip you can
say v skip the baseline skip
when when tech
starts its v skip instruction it'll call
scan glue to figure out how much it's
supposed to skip by so v skip
can be followed by the
now
let's look at the syntax a little bit of
of uh
uh look at the syntax of
of uh glue what does it consist of well
it consists of a dimension
and then optionally
plus
sorry plus a
dimension
and optionally minus
a dimension
we know that in order to scan these
words plus and minus we're going to have
that scan keyword subroutine and we got
scanned them in to do this to do this
thing
well
but now if you think about it
demand starts with a
demand like you know 10 points starts
with scan int
one of the dimensions can also be um
apostrophe 77 point you can give a
dimensions in octal so it has to start
with this with scanning integer you can
say count five points things like that
so demand
can start with an integer and uh fur and
glue can start with the demand
and all of these can be the so when i
call the here
um
uh okay if it says the baseline skip
that would substitute for all of this
but if it says the
var unit
that's a dimension
or the h size or v size say uh that's a
dimension that would leave us that would
leave us only at the first part and we
still have to look for plus again
and the if it was if it was a count or
some other or some uh
other integer register like the
uh the time or something like that all
kinds of integers that can occur uh who
would like to be skipped by the time of
day but why not
um
then it has to be followed by then
that's only part of a dimension so after
we finish so so we have a subroutine of
tech called scanda but it doesn't know
what what it's going to wind up with it
might wind up with it with glue the
whole whole piece of glue it might wind
up with a dimension it might wind up
with just an integer
so
besides curval
where which contains the result of scan
the
we also have curval level
which tells what kind of a thing it
found
and so the curve l level will be set to
either int val or demenval or gluval
telling you what kind of a thing you got
so so after you've called so you call a
subroutine called scanda and
looks ahead to see what what's what's
following
and afterwards if it found
a baseline skip
full piece of glue then curve l level
will be
we'll say glue val
and curve val will be a pointer to the
specification of the glue that uh that
that was found so you can figure out
what you got
um
that was the
main uh uh
unusual
aspect of the design of these particular
subroutines
now you these things are also recursive
because if you see what's going on if
you say
if you're trying to scan an integer
integer starts with the word count
then um which counter are you doing you
have to give a number between 250 and
255 and that's an integer so you have so
so uh
scan
so so scanning an integer can ask
can
reduce to uh scanning an integer or
scanning the i mean you could say count
the something or other
and that would give you one of the
counters and so the
scan the has to call scan in scan in
tests to call scanned up or and scan in
and so on so these procedures are
mutually recursive um
but they they keep on getting further
and further into the input so they don't
uh if they don't get into a loop of
course
question yeah yeah it seems almost that
what you're asking it to do there is
identical to what you're asking it to do
when it expands macros i'm a little
curious about why you didn't do it the
same way
in the in the uh get next routine itself
yeah that simply have glue parameters in
fact b macros and we have them expand
token lists
well the easy answer is i didn't think
of it but uh
and
but
i i haven't got a simple
otherwise this is the way that occurred
to me to do this yeah
um
now the
uh okay so
so uh
i'd like to look at in the remaining
five minutes i'd like to look at one of
these in a little more detail so you can
get a little more feeling for it by
taking a suggestion from the audience
what do you think would be a good one to
pursue
just to get a feeling for what what what
what's totally involved here or
or you don't want to look at any of them
what
lynn's tell me
no idea what to do
okay well let's take a look at uh at the
details of scanning
a demand then
scan demand
starts on
module 400
and
when we look at what actually has to be
done now the the job of scan demand is
going to be to put in curville
um a
a an integer in scaled points
uh or in other words a scaled quantity
uh and the units are
2 to the 16th uh to the minus 16th
points
and this
is supposed to be something that all
versions of tech82 will will will
arrive at exactly the same number it's
quite important to to uh
to design the language so that it's
machine independent in this way
now there's but it turns out there's
three uh parameters to this when you
start looking at what scandal dimension
has to
has to handle
and the first parameter is called mu
because of
of things in math mode
when
in math mode when you when you say m
m skip
or m kern
to give spacing in math mode
you're not supposed to say three
three points you're supposed to say
three mu which is three math units and
this is a variable unit that will change
whether or not you're in a subscript or
something like that
but
but math units are not allowed outside
of this outside of these contexts so
scan demand takes the first panel or mu
which is either true or false saying
whether whether the units are supposed
to be mu or not
most of the um the next parameter to
scan the men
is
called inf
and um
this
this says whether or not it'll allow the
units to be
infinite
there are three versions of infinity
fill
phillip and philalil
and uh if anybody knows a poem by ogden
nash about
a 1l lama as a priest the tula lama is a
beast and
he bet something that they'll never see
a three a llama or something like that
well we don't have four l fills in this
in this language not now um
um
uh but
this
this in parameter is to scan to men is
uh
is true or false depending on whether or
not um such things are
are legal
and they're only legal after plus or
minus
so so usually that parameter is false
and the third parameter is called
shortcut and and that says and that's
because uh when you're scanning a
dimension you might already have built
up part of that dimension uh and you're
ready to go right to the to to the part
that adds up the uh that inserts the uh
uh points or whatever
and uh uh because you might have called
the and it gave you an integer and then
that and so you're halfway through into
your scanning dimension already so so
you wanna uh you to pass by that first
part of the routine so
those are three parameters to scan them
in most of the time when i want to get a
dimension though in one of my semantic
routines i'll call scan the men of false
false false because all of those other
cases haven't arisen there's no shortcut
no mew and no infinite glue
allow
okay now scan them in is i'm looking at
module 401
and
i have a
fairly large procedure here but if you
but but i think by by reading it
in this module form we get we boil it
down to uh in this case a little more
than 12 lines
but we can see exactly what all what all
it has to do um
f is the an integer is the numerator of
a fraction whose denominator is 2 to the
16th the big problem in scandaman is
going to be to preserve this machine
independence to make sure i do all my
fixed point arithmetic with numbers that
would fit on 32-bit machine
and also i have to check for arithmetic
overflow that might occur then during
these calculations
the cur order this is the global
variable that's going to if if i do find
infinite blue i have to tell somebody
whether which kind of fill it was with
with one two or three else so the cur
order is going to be normal
unless i found some special glue
negative is something i set false and
that will
flip back and forth if i find minus
signs in front of the darn thing
negative means should the answer be
negated
um okay then if not shortcut then i have
to do all this stuff
which gets the integer part or the uh
gets the essentially sets up a value um
uh for
for uh incur val containing um
uh
containing the integer part of the
dimension
and f is the fraction part of the
by the time i finish this loop then i've
got some integer plus a fraction over 2
to the 16th that's got to be
finished up with units supplied so let's
look at this first part which we do in
case of a short
get the next non-blank non-sign token
set negative appropriately
and so this is really going to pass up
minus signs and plus signs that might be
at the beginning and blanks um then we
have to check if it's the
or register register is what comes up if
you say count or
demand or one of the
internal things for for uh
one of text internal
registers
in that case then we uh
have to do a special thing
that either fetches an internal integer
or for an internal dimension
if we find a whole dimension like if we
find the
um
v size then we get then we get to go to
attach sine because we've got the whole
thing in in the right units
but if we just get an integer then we
continue on and we have to figure out
this points or centimeters or whatever
um
if we didn't have the in that other case
we back up the input
uh get ready to read the token again and
check to see whether we with a decimal
point or not
and uh
if it was a decimal point we have to set
decimal radix and uh
and can and uh and
in other words uh the whole thing might
have started with a decimal point you
can say 0.1 you don't have to say 0.1
um
and if you start with a point then you
you're
getting into a base 10 thing here
if you look at this code you'll see what
happens if a guy just says a decimal
point and doesn't say zero either before
or after it but just a period and then
pt or something like that and it turns
out that that's zero
but i hope people don't use that
now
okay that's the way the thing goes
and uh the
on the next page we have one of the
prettiest modules the way the way it
gets formatted by weave
on elsif's i guess anyway this is where
we're just looking for all the different
kinds of units
that
that can arise and
and we have to convert inches to points
uh by
by calling a macro here set conversion
which will um
uh takes two parameters a numerating
denominator since essentially
multiplying by
72 27 dividing by 100 to get in inches
into points
uh this is uh my definition of a point
there's i've searched for a standard
official definition of what is a point
and uh not found uh not found
a
pronouncement of the bureau of standards
or anything like that that the
uh the reference sources give
give more or less significant figures
and the ones that that gave the most
significant figures were all consistent
with this value so uh it's nice simple
fraction
i'm choosing it
as a definition of of in of an inch to a
point um
and uh as i wanted to emphasize again
all this arithmetic has been carefully
designed so that it will not
um
uh it will round well and it will and it
will not go over 32-bit calculations
and give a give a decent answer
okay any questions before we break
so these are the routines that there is
one yeah
uh this is a question mainly on web and
philosophy the get next shows that you
use labels to find labels in one module
that aren't actually decla defined until
x number of modules later do you find
this to be a problem in uh well i wish
that yeah i wish that that was um
that
that pascal had had a better setup for
those but actually what i did with the
uh
is is almost all the labels in the
program are defined once and for all at
the beginning and i
probably have mentioned that in my first
lecture in in module 15
it tells about this i um
i have labels that that are are used in
in ways that uh are
are are quite common
uh
in order to in order to do things so
exit is is generally is is generally
just before the end of a subroutine and
there's done uh to get out of loops and
found and things like this continue and
these are used in in ways that are that
are always
the same as if i had if i had a
programming language that supported it
and uh
so
these are there's
general uh a few uh
idioms that are used in the in the
programming and there and the labels
were defined once and for all here
i uh only a few places will we have a
special label like attach sign
and and in that case uh
if you notice the attached sign was
defined in the module but also also
carried through in in the names of other
modules that we're going to go to attach
sign it's very important when you give
the name of a module that if it if
there's some something funny about the
control structure that that gets into
the name of the module
that was one of the important things we
learned about
formulating these these rules
um but
most of the things if we had
reprogrammed this to be
done with with uh very few go-to
statements it would have turned out i
believe the program would have been a
lot less readable and a lot slower just
because of the way that programming
languages are working
and uh
if you don't believe me we can debate
this after class and that's the that's
but that is a firmly held belief of
philosophy after doing a lots of lots of
coding in this form we tried to have
have these labels on module 15 uh
is part of the style of programming
that's represented in this in this code
but but uh for example exit
i have a i've defined return to be go to
exit that's very and pascal didn't have
a return statement so
we just do that now that means that i
have to remember when i use the return
statement and procedure i have to
remember to declare the label exit at
the beginning and to put it there at the
end
it wasn't much of a hassle to remember
that though
okay thanks a lot we'll see you again at
11 o'clock